[Music]
tonight how could oscar pistorius not
have realized he was about to kill his
girlfriend
you knew the dreamer was behind the door
and you shot Anthony the athlete insist
she didn't shout out he wasn't scared of
anything
except you good evening from the
courtroom in Pretoria where Oscar
Pistorius has faced another grueling day
of cross-examination the athletes been
questioned about the moment that he shot
through this toilet door killing reeva
Steenkamp Kareem L said it was beyond
belief that she would have remained
silent and he must have known that she
was there behind this door Lisa Holland
reports on another dramatic day in court
Oscar Pistorius has spent nearly a week
in the witness box it ended with a
blistering finale by the prosecution but
the day began with the prosecutor having
to clarify evidence from yesterday he
had criticized the athlete for using the
courtroom to apologize to reeva
Steenkamp smother and her family instead
of talking to them in private
after the general yesterday she informed
me through advocate that mr. Pistorius
did in fact request a meeting with the
Stinkum family prior to the trial but
they were not ready for such a me and
I'm putting the entry so it's
confirmation of what was said that
yesterday
and mr. stinking thought that it was
important that we put it in or I could I
didn't know about that before for
yesterday thank you for Harry now
questioned the Olympian about his belief
that crime isn't properly investigated
in South Africa Oscar Pistorius said he
had been a victim of crime on several
occasions but the prosecutor wanted to
know why he had never reported it why
why did you not do do that if you've
been exposed to prom before my lady the
you can go through the list of the
Crown's that I've been exposed to the
hospitals when I got back to South
Africa as I said the house breaking was
a week was a week or more earlier there
was a TV missing I didn't think that
anything could be done about it I didn't
have insurance at the time there was no
reason for me to open up or to go to a
police station and report the crime
when I was shot at on the highway I
didn't want to go to the police station
I didn't think they'd be able to do
anything about it I'm sure you agree
with that if somebody should set you on
a highway that's a very serious milady
one could die it's correct milady and
you well for really all the questions
are I have to ask a different question
why did you not report it to the police
I don't see what the police could have
possibly done about it why do you say
that
police police investigate cases they
they can find things out but you didn't
trust them
that's correct my lady I didn't have the
trust in them to find out what but I
don't think they would have given it the
attention after allegedly being shot at
Oscar Pistorius says he couldn't
remember who came to pick him up
prompting the prosecutor to suggest he
had made the episode up
it is so improbably that you wouldn't
remember who you phoned and it's so
improbable that in consultation he
wouldn't have been asked the same
question first
so you counseled to find out who you
fight I don't I don't know who I find my
lady my counsel did ask me and I told
them I don't know because it never
happened you don't want anybody to check
up that's the only reason why you would
forget to pick you up that night that
somebody almost shot me that's not true
milady
it's the one night that somebody almost
shot you am i right
that's correct milady and you can
remember raps you remember exactly where
you turned left when you turned right
and how you got to traps it exactly
that's correct what I did but you you do
not remember who you find that doesn't
make sense
that's great that doesn't make sense you
don't want anybody to be able to check
up on this the prosecutor lepton what he
said was a discrepancy in Oscar
pistorius's ever
over the alarm system at his Pretoria
home this is now the biggest indication
of you tailoring evidence you cannot
have made that mistake it's impossible
to do mr. Lau please read the context
and not seeing nothing I'm asking you
why did you make the mistakes you cannot
explain a mistake in the way that you're
doing your tailoring your evidence you
could not have made that mistake my lady
my understanding is that they're two
different incidents mysteries I'm gonna
take you up on this answer but I'm
coming for her because you're getting
deeper into trouble the athlete was
asked whether he had switched off the
alarm after the shooting
then contradicted himself we get lots of
mistakes this morning mr. Christopher
I'm tired m'lady oh I'm sorry if I got
the wrong word I mean I must have turned
my alarm off it makes sense to me that I
switched it off nobody else could have
switched it off didn't go off when I ran
through the house didn't go off for the
later stage and only makes sense to me
that I searched it all you see your
answer now puts me in a predicament are
you too tired to continue because I
don't want a response again today that
I'm tired and therefore I made a mistake
sir I want you to please the other port
if you try at any one time we will
discuss it with your legal team well
it's not that one time it's from tired
I'm gonna be tired
I don't need time I am tired
it's not going to change I understand
the predicament that mr. Knowles in it's
just a city bears with me I've made a
mistake I've admitted to making a
mistake
with respect mr. Pistorius and I'm just
saying that I'm not convinced about your
answer now I think that you're trying to
cover up for lies and I'm not convinced
so mysterious it's important that you
should be all here when I in that
witness box you understand that not to
you my lady
so if you are tired and the reason
you're making all these mistakes is
because you tie it you must say so it
doesn't help to say it's not gonna
change I understand my lady I am tired
m'lady but I made a mistake with the way
I answered the question the question is
are you too tired to proceed normally
because you you can be at a disadvantage
when you are in that box you understand
you understand that yes it can be fed to
you and it's not fair to this court
either I understand well can we accept
it you not you haven't made this
mistakes because you tired Kenny acts 17
doc can accept that m'lady
no can we accept that are you small ad
the Rana said he put his prosthetic legs
near the bedroom sliding doors to air
but mr. Nell said that meant they'd be
in the way of his route to the balcony
where he says he screamed for help are
you getting emotional yes I'm very
emotional and why because it's a
difficult time for me to remember but
but why would this question make here
motion because this is not unless the
person that I cared about
I don't know how people don't understand
but after three days of relentless
cross-examination for oscar pistorius
the prosecutor known in south african
circles as the pit bull got this warning
from the judge
please mr. mell get my India language
what it does only you don't call a
witness a liar not while he's in the
witness box but there was no let-up in
Harry Nell's determination to destroy
Oscar pistorius's version of events
he took the athlete back to the night of
reeva Steenkamp steth they were in the
bedroom awake when Oscar Pistorius says
he heard the bathroom window slide open
I told Weaver to get down to find the
police Arijit Ellen I was fitted to her
m'lady I said it in a soft tone now did
you look at her when you sit there no
m'lady from the time that I left the
amplifier to the time I got my fire I
tried not to keep get my eyes off the
passage I see now
when you heard the noise you never
discussed the noise with her I did not
discuss the noise or service here is it
Reba did you hear that
I didn't say that m'lady I uh did you
say that I did not want a whiner she's
awake I was not confused about what I'd
heard milady
you shouldn't be confused but they do
not check with her if you care about
River he will make sure that she hears
you that she's dead you didn't I was
sure that she was there my lady because
I had spoken to him shortly before
before when I got out of bed and just
before I got out of bed she she spoke to
me so at that time I thought she was in
the bed I spoke to even I said to get
down call the police
I say mr. Pistorius
a reasonable person would have looked
where Reaver was look if she was saying
and if she panics but you didn't you
just grabbed a gun welcome back the
state prosecutor continued his fierce
grilling of Oscar Pistorius about the
moment he shot and killed his girlfriend
reeva Steenkamp beside this toilet door
he was asked what was going through his
mind why he grabbed his gun released the
safety catch and headed towards the
bathroom after he said he'd heard a
noise I was never ready to shoot my lady
at any point was I ready to shoot so I
was trying to get and see what was
happening in my home but why would you
go if you're not why would you arm
yourself rush towards the danger but
you're not ready to shoot that's not
true
not on your version even nobody I didn't
have time to think I was dealt with the
situation in which I had to protect
breva and I had to protect myself it's
not that easy you cannot tell the court
I didn't see you armed yourself and I'm
sure you release the safety sweep the
safety mechanism on your gun that's
great you vulnerable but you go towards
the danger that's correct excellent why
would you do that because if I'd stayed
where I was milady river and I would be
in danger nobody would have been in
danger because there was no intruder if
you stayed in that room people would
have been alive somebody could have shot
River they came in my room and they
sprayed mace in my room something could
have happened once it's put as much
distance as I could between Riva and
what I'll never see to be the danger it
was the one person that didn't even talk
to if you remained in the bedroom you
had a clear view of the passage somebody
coming out of the bathroom I had to walk
at least five meters to get to you
instinct would have made sure Reba he
say mother I do you think everybody's
instinct is different
that's what's instinct
I thought that she was safe and in the
process of what I did I was thinking
that I was making it safer for you and
Reva could have gone out the main
bedroom thing we could have Molly why
did you not do I'm not sure my leg is
very easy to not look back and talk
about all the possibilities but they
that is not what happened
your whole version is what to explain
why you got to the boss innocence that's
why the one major issue of the bedroom
door you cannot explain
m'lady if you'd listened to mrs.
Taylor's evidence where she said that
when there was an intruder I went
downstairs and I look is that smart
personality my lady that's all I am so
instead of caring and running away at
that split moment I wanted to put myself
between the danger at me Oscar I want to
go to confront them that's correct and
that for myself that's correct if I see
them I'll shoot them that's not what I
said or shouting and I was screaming and
they were very large I was shouting at
the people to get off then you got to
the entrance to the bathroom
that's correct milady and you get why I
didn't want to give my position away I
was scared that the person was around
the corner
I had my firearm in front of me this
wasn't my second everything about that
event was split-decision my lady every
moment there was a difference in
something that could have happened a
different situation somebody could have
attacked me with the firearm or they
could have just ran after me I choked me
m'lady that's why it doesn't make sense
that you approach them it's a lie when
did you hear the ocean that was when I
was in the passage one day just before I
entered above that there was either
somebody's getting going into the toilet
so that somebody had kicked the door
it's the door opens up was it strange
that it was closed or did that not make
it a difference it wasn't strange at all
milady I've heard it's damn close you
either had some big kick a door slam it
closed I never ever said I heard
somebody kick the door my lady
said I heard the door slam closed you
said it's one of two things either it
was slammed closed or somebody kicked
the door in them fleeing the house
that's correct I'm sorry my lady mistake
must be I am I'm thinking of something
that never happened and I have to keep
up that's it
your version never happened and you have
to keep up with an untruth it's not the
mistake it's you saying I never ever
said somebody kick the door that is for
me that's what it's about not the fact
that you made a mistake that you were so
convinced that you never said I
understand what as convinced as you are
about the rest of the evidence that is
my problem
I'm putting with you that your mistakes
are as convincing as your evidence in
the way you deliver it it's improbable
that you would even think that it
included running tomato Latin and dr.
doe I had to consider that there was
someone in the toilet or that there was
somebody on the letter River at that
stage his three meters away from you in
a toilet
and she never uttered a word that's
correct
it's not boss it's not probable she
would be scared she would shut out and
talk to you you in the same room my lady
I agree with mr. no she would have been
terrified my lady was shouting and I was
approaching the toilet and she was in
the I was approaching the bathroom as
she was in the toilet then I presume
that she would think that the danger is
coming closer to so why would she shot
odds because you in the room sir mr.
Pistorius you now in the room you shot
in she's three meters away from you
beyond that particular door there is no
way that you can win support that she
stood there saying she was standing
right in front of the boat clear the
door talking to you when you shot it
that's the only reasonable explanation
first and
right that's only reasonable explanation
while you shut that in the hip where you
did it's not true Molly she wasn't
scared of anything except you she wasn't
scared of an intruder you're scared of
you if your version is true she would
not have been in front of that door
facing you God think anybody could say
where she would have stood if she was if
she was thinking that I was no mind it
must have been that I was retreating to
the bathroom in her mind I must have
been retreating screaming for even
firing the police while waiting for the
people to get out she was in the toilet
then she would have been quite I don't
see why she would have screamed odds if
she thought you're a treating that gives
her more reason to talk to say you
coming to me can you come no Thomas I'll
phone the police lady River had been
involved in a similar incident before in
her life where she locked herself away
from my understanding that she wasn't
able to speak to people for a day or so
after with my lady so I don't think that
it's the case are you sure mr. pistou it
is that Riva did not scream after the
first shot shots scream I wish she let
me know she was there she did not do
that is he he just listened to my
question after you fired the first shot
did she scream are you sure yes would
you have heard her I don't think I would
have him she can't shut that window
milady my ears were ringing that's what
I'm that's why I'm asking you the
question how can you exclude the fact
that you were screaming if you couldn't
hear people heard a woman scream during
the shots is that possible no that's not
possible why because her woman didn't
scream at any point well now you don't
say that I cannot say no when screamed
during the shots I can say no one
screamed my lady went women screaming it
wasn't a woman screaming Wow
how can you say that are you making a
mistake again the mistake is you forgot
about you ears ringing I'm not talking
about the shoe to my lady I'm talking
about the entire evening I'm talking
about the shoe thing you've got get away
with that every time that you don't know
what I'm talking about sometimes you
have to take responsibility
in fact you knew the driver was behind
the door and you shot at sir that is the
only thing that makes sense it's a
dramatic end to a dramatic week Oscar
Pistorius has spent five days in the
witness box here and he's got more to
come now a two and a half day break as
he waits and wonders what mr. nail is
gonna throw at him on Monday well
joining me now Alex Crawford our
correspondent in court and Delia
Jeffrey's is a local attorney welcome to
you both Alex we've certainly seen the
contrasting sides of his character
Carrie now has made a lot during his
cross-examinations mainly mostly been
centered even today there were hints of
his as well that Oscar Pistorius in his
view is a very narcissistic personality
and that even when he's been giving
evidence he pointed out today that he
had didn't consider how reeva Steenkamp
would have been feeling inside that very
confined space when four bullets came
firing through the door he was more
concerned with how upset he was how
frightened he was how overwhelmed with
fear he was as he headed out towards
that toilet door and I think that has
been really riling Oscar Pistorius
however I thought he did pretty well
today despite the mistakes and despite
the rowing back and he seemed to be
emotionally much stronger than he has
been in the previous days did you I
wonder why you feel this trial stands at
the end of this perhaps the most
dramatic week of all are we getting to
the very crux of this case we get into
very thin point cross-examination over
here and it's very sad job to get
concessions out of Oscar which he's been
making
at regular intervals but it's attacking
him back to the scene
every so often and more and more so to
me is an indication that he's honing in
on what the real issue is over here and
leaving the other issues that he's been
charged with to become lesser and lesser
almost like fading into the background
he hops around but in his scenario that
he or that he puts to the accused but
also I think that there is to either put
him in a comfort zone that he can feel
strong about certain of his evidence and
then to come back and rattle in with the
real evidence
thank you very much Tara and Alex so
maybe the coup de Grasse on Monday or
Tuesday of next week as Oscar Pistorius
continues his difficult time in the
witness box don't forget you can join us
again in court
live from 8:30 London time on Monday
[Music]